foreign
[Music]
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
question and answer program I'd like to
know
we're glad that you decided to join us
today we have some very very captivating
questions that have come in I just want
to remind you that if you do send in
questions be patient with us because we
receive more questions than we're able
to answer in one or two programs we will
answer yours eventually but be patient
and keep tuning in and you will see the
answer that we provide let me give you
the address where you can write your
questions to us it's on the screen TV at
some tv.org once again TV at some
tv.org once again thank you for being
with us I have with me my good friend
and fellow laborer in the Lord's cause
David Salazar Pastor David Salazar it's
wonderful to have you
to help answer these questions on this
program thank you Pastor it's a blessing
and always an honor and privilege for me
to be able to share this time to with
you and and going to the Bible and
answer the questions that our friends
send amen and uh of course we should
never open the Bible without prayer so
would you please pray for us that the
Lord will bless our program absolutely
Heavenly Father Lord as we come before
you at this hour we thank you for
allowing us to go to your word and to
understand and to study and to get the
lessons and the answers to the questions
that our friends have sent in ourselves
we are not capable of answering anything
right but because we submit ourselves to
you we ask that you will send your Holy
Spirit to lead us into all truth and to
give us the right answers and the words
that may speak from our lips be words
that affirm your word and teach the
truth to those that are listening we
pray all these in Jesus name amen amen
okay here comes the first question that
I'm going to throw at you okay
[Laughter]
I've never heard this question asked
before although there are other biblical
cases that are similar to this uh it
says like this I have never understood
the brutality of men against women in
the Old Testament I might add also men
against men of course the story of the
Levi light and the concubine never made
sense to me
why did he destroy and treat her body so
brutally it makes me sick every time I
read it I complete an annual Bible
reading plan so can't avoid it what was
the purpose for this story in judges 19
and 20. it's the famous story of the
levite and the concubine so how do we
explain the brutality that the Bible
describes in this story well Pastor the
story is certainly one of those stories
that is very disturbing as we read
through the details of the story we
don't have time to go through the whole
story but it's one of those stories that
even to myself have always you know I
always have the same question as our
friend has you know why the details why
the you know the acts and the actions of
these men levite happened you know with
his concubine
but we have to remember that the word of
God is not going to just tell us
something that is nice or that is gonna
sugar coat what happens when sin Reigns
in the life of someone I believe the
stories in the Bible all stories really
point us to the conflict that we are
experiencing on this Earth between good
and evil we always have this issue of uh
or this situation that is happening in
the world between those that are seeking
to follow the lord follow the truth
follow Christ and those that are
following the influence and the
dictations of the heart the heart is
speaks that is desperately wicked the
heart of man the natural heart the
natural man is desperately wicked
there's no end to how low someone can go
so the story is portraying you and is
giving you an example of what happens to
someone who
seems to be a Christian or seems to
follow the Lord but in reality even
these people were you know they were
supposed to be Israelites and following
the Lord but you can see the
consequences of sin and how evil how
load sin can take you so I believe that
God really allowed this story to give us
a clear understanding of sin and the
results of sin and thrown in the heart
yeah you know Ellen White Once wrote
the inhumanity of man to man is our
greatest sin right and basically I agree
with you that the story uh simply shows
what happens when sin is in control of a
person's life right even people who
claim to be followers of Jesus you know
can be very cruel in fact Ellen White
stated that when the Holy Spirit is
withdrawn from the earth the heart of
man can be very cruel when it is devoid
of the spirit of God you know you look
at what happened during the 1260 years
of papal persecution I mean people were
burned at the stake for what they
believed people were you know put in the
rack many different systems of torture
because he didn't agree with the
teachings and practices of the church it
just goes to show what happens when
people are under the control of Satan
absolutely remembering the in the Roman
you know days they would put Nicolas
little children to be eaten you know by
wild beasts so you have you know and
people actually were rejoicing they saw
that as a spectacular as entertainment
and sadly
if we just look at today's society and
how low has we have come as people as
human beings you realize that the same
atrocities that happen in the past are
happening even now even among those that
are called themselves Christian
it's really disturbing for us to see
that sin is being put in a pedestal
nowadays and truth and what's right put
us and you know as outdated as not
important as irrelevant but the results
are clearly seen in this story I believe
and stories like this show us exactly
what will happen when the heart the
human heart is let free to do as it
pleases and the condition of the time of
Noah Before the Flood was something as
as it was there similar to that and the
same thing will happen at the end time
through the course of history
men have abused their headship role or
their leadership role yeah and that has
led to in a great degree to the women's
rights movement
you know the men to a certain degree are
to blame right for for the reaction of
the women in society today
um you know but you look also in the Old
Testament in many cases a brutality of
men towards men of course I mean and
ultimately the common denominator is sin
in the heart I'd like to read uh from
Romans chapter 3. and beginning at verse
10 where the Apostle Paul describes
the situation of people who are living
in sin
it says as it is written there is none
righteous no not one
there is none who understands there is
none who seeks after God they have all
turned aside they have together become
unprofitable there is none who does good
no not one their throat is an open Tomb
with their tongues they have practiced
deceit the poison of asps is under their
lips whose mouth is full of cursing and
bitterness their feet are Swift to shed
blood destruction and misery are in
their ways and the way of peace they
have not known there is no fear of God
before their eyes as we look at the
world today it's becoming more and more
clear that there is no fear in the heart
of human beings by the way that they
treat other people and as you mentioned
Pastor is not you know just one gender
over the other or something like that we
know the stories in the Bible that
portray for example how some mothers
will even eat their own children I mean
you're talking about the atrocities of
them of of the love of a mother to a
child so we cannot just you know look at
this and say you know what happened with
a certain gender or what happened to the
roles the problem is really beyond that
the sin is the problem and how it
creates this desire to go deeper and
deeper into degradation into immorality
into destruction so as we can see the
only solution is really turning to the
Lord and God can give the answer and
this word of God kind of tells us and
this is why the stories are there so we
can see how the Lord can redeem people
from that condition from that experience
from that type of behavior or or or
level of brutality and how can the Lord
really give the answer in his word
through his love and through his uh of
the truth of the word of God you know
you have the example of Simeon and Levi
who killed all of the men uh in the city
of a second I mean
talk about talk about
cruelty towards fellow human beings and
that is the case of men against men so
you know sin uh is an equal opportunity
employer
we might say yeah absolutely you know if
maybe I could recommend a book because
some people wonder about uh you know God
for example uh the massacre of the of
the nations in Canaan when Israel
entered the promised land and you know
how could God destroy an entire
civilization or tell Israel to do it you
know how could God destroy the cities of
Sodom and Gomorrah how could God uh you
know destroy the world by a flood and so
on uh you know people have a tendency to
blame God for all those things there's a
book that we carry it was written by
Steve Wahlberg who is the president of
Whitehurst media it's the best book I've
ever read on the issue of does God
destroy or does not God destroy and who
is responsible for all of these acts in
the Old Testament and I would recommend
this book to everyone who is watching
this program it's called the character
of God controversy and Steve in this
book actually goes through many
different stories of the Old Testament
and shows that we cannot hold God
accountable and responsible for all of
these bad things it is the sinfulness of
human beings ultimately that leads to
this amen amen I think that you know a
verse that we can sort of remember is
the one found in Isaiah 49 15.
you know
um or actually the 14 and 15 says but
Zion said the Lord had forsaken me and
my Lord had forgotten me then he says
can a woman forget her cycling child
that she should not have compassion the
son of her womb yeah they may forget yet
will I not forget thee in other words I
believe we have to remember that
true compassion true love only comes
from God and even though we are
we can be disturbed by the stories
ultimately we have to understand that
the character of God is a character of
compassion of love and mercy and Justice
and and when we see his
his ways and how he acts how he
interacts with us with us sinners I
believe we will see the reason why these
stories are there in a more positive
light to understand that God does not
want does not rejoice in the Sin and the
problem but trying to find an exit to
that and save us from that
same issue which is in our hearts and
unless we repent and come to the Lord
things that are worse than that we may
be able to participate or be part of and
so this is why it's also
somewhat of a warning as well to us
well let's go to our next question
there's a lot we could say more about
this individual has written but I think
that we've kind of put our finger on the
real problem and that is the problem of
sin absolutely okay the next question is
um a very interesting question uh hello
pastors I have two questions actually
there's two
it's a reference to the verse in Isaiah
11 verse 8 about the infant and weaned
child any idea where these children come
from because if there were any children
that were taken to heaven we would have
already been there for a thousand years
so every person would be at least a
thousand years old at that point and
since there is no marrying or given in
marriage it doesn't seem like anybody
would be having children either if it is
after the Millennium what am I missing
here seems like the children in this
verse are back on the renewed Earth so
um I think we understand the question uh
you know there's going to be children
according to Isaiah 11 verse 8 and uh
and yet the thousand years have passed
uh since uh you know when God makes a
new Heavens in the north so how do we
explain this well uh you know it's
interesting that this question is made
and honestly is one thing that I have
not come across before you know there's
some questions like how will the
children be in the new Earth
um first of all we do have a quote from
Spirit prophecy that's rather actually
in another program where we actually
find that she sees the Lord Angels
carrying little infants when he comes
some of them to their matters and
parents and some of them are without
parents and so those are taken to to be
to heaven or you know with those that
are redeemed nevertheless
we are sort of assuming that this
experience here is only in the new Earth
in other words after 1000 years
however the
the interpretation or the the context of
the verse is not necessarily speaking
that this is going to happen in the
north and we are sort of going I think
stepping beyond the clear indication
from the word of God about families and
what will happen in the future we are
sort of trying to still be like the
Sadducees where they're trying to entrap
Jesus with the idea of of a man and a
woman and you know will that happen in
heaven and he said to them it's not like
we know it here on Earth it's a little
it's going to be different we're like
Angels so some of the things some
details that are for us right now Veil
we don't see them we need to just rest
in the Lord he will show as I explained
to us now in the verse that she mentions
about the aspect of the child you know
playing with the you know with the aspid
and uh with a lion and with the calf and
playing together and all those things
and how the child will lead them it's
it's more of a promise I believe it's is
I mean it's it's real literal but also
the promise of the restoration of the
new Earth of the new heavens of the
newer the experience that we lost in the
beginning so it is a promise it's a
prophecy of what will happen when the
Lord restores
our our lost home which was you know in
before the same came to the world yeah
we also need to understand that uh here
Isaiah is also writing to to literal
Israel
and literal Israel did not meet the
conditions if literal Israel had met the
conditions
perhaps this is exactly what would have
happened
but uh you know what did not happen
there uh with literal Israel will happen
in the Kingdom with spiritual Israel
right right and this is a beautiful
description uh you know uh here that is
given about uh how the animal world will
be in Perfect Harmony uh you know there
won't be uh animal eating animal
so we better not get too addicted to
McDonald's here because there's not
going to be any death absolutely in the
coming Kingdom I praise the Lord to that
I think like you know the principles are
important sometimes the details that the
Lord has not revealed to us are better
not to to ask and and you know seek
answers because we don't really have a
clear answer from the word of God
um you know and so but but you said I I
think that it's it's important that we
remember that is also a promise that was
given to the Israelites and the literal
Israel yeah okay the second question is
Revelation 20 17 and 18 tells the fowls
to eat the Flesh of Kings captains
Mighty Men but I was thinking there was
a Bible verse that referenced that even
the animals would be destroyed when
Jesus returns for the second time only
leaving Satan and his angels to think
about what they've done for a thousand
years
for the life of me I can't find that
verse but what's trying to reconcile
those two verses how can the fowls be
feasted on Kings Etc if they have been
destroyed but since I can't find the
second verse
maybe I'm remembering it wrong is there
such a verse do you know maybe it's not
important well it's not it's not that
it's not important all questions are
important that are sent here right we
don't demean any question that anybody
asks but it's of course a question that
hasn't to do has not to do with
salvation
but what we need to understand is that
in the Bible
uh foul are used as a symbol of Satan
and his demons
so this is symbolic language we're not
we're not supposed to see uh you know
the kings of the earth and all these
birds are coming to eat the Flesh of
these Kings of the earth uh Revelation
chapter 19 is a symbolic portrayal that
teaches great realities for example
Jesus comes Seated on a white horse well
Jesus isn't going to come literally
sitting on a white horse with a sword
coming out of his mouth and you know
he's gonna he's gonna tread a little
wine press of literal grapes you know
all of this is symbolic the grapes are
symbolic of the wicked he's going to
trample on the wicked he's going to
destroy the Wicked the sword out of his
mouth is his word he's going to utter
his word so behind the symbolism is
powerful reality Jesus is coming correct
and he's gonna he's going to cry out for
the resurrection of his people he's
going to utter his word and you know so
so it's a symbolic portrayal of real
things that are going to occur in the
Bible
um
we find in Revelation chapter 18 in fact
what the fowls represent what the birds
represent so let's go to Revelation
chapter 18. this is talking about
Babylon in the end time
um it says in chapter 18 and verse 2 and
he cried mightily with a loud voice
saying Babylon the greatest Fallen has
fallen and has become a Dwelling Place
of demons now there's going to be three
synonymous lines here
Babylon has become
uh
has become the dwelling place of demons
a prison for every foul spirit
and a cage for every unclean and hated
bird
so so in other words Babylon is full of
foul Spirits which are symbolized by
birds
okay so uh who is going to be causing
all of this massacre at the second
coming of Christ well it's going to be
Satan and his angels influencing the
wicked that in fact they're going to
kill one another because of the
influence of of Satan when and his
angels are doing in the Bible beasts
are used as symbols
of uh leaders right who are opposed to
God's people I have several in uh
examples here
uh Psalm 74 18 and 19.
says remember this that the enemy has
reproached oh Lord
and that a foolish people has blasphemed
your name so it refers to the enemy
reproaching the Lord the foolish people
blaspheming God's name
and then in verse 19 the psalmist says
oh do not deliver the life of your
turtle dove to the wild beast well the
fact is the psalmist was not a turtle
dove
and his enemy was not was not a beast
it's using symbolic language in other
words uh Psalm 7 1-2 Lord my God in you
I put my trust save me from all those
who persecute me talking about people
who are persecuted him and Deliver Me
lest they tear me like a lion
see it's comparing yes the wicked to a
lion to a lion rending Me In Pieces
while there is none to deliver and I
have many many other uh examples here
the Messianic Psalm Psalm 22 12 and 13
uh speaking about Jesus on the cross
many bulls have surrounded me well the
the Wicked at the foot of the cross are
compared to Bulls of course strong Bulls
of Bastion have encircled me they gape
at me with their mouths like a raging
and roaring lion so so the Wicked at the
foot of the cross are compared to strong
bulls and lies the Satan and his angels
are compared to the fowls of the air
according to what we read in Revelation
chapter 18.
um let me just give you one more example
uh well maybe one or two this is on the
death of Jerome during the Middle Ages
right uh speaking about his enemies that
says there their thirst for blood
wedded by the death of Huss clamored for
fresh victims
so in other words it's like an animal
thirsting for blood to destroy the
martyrs and the Apostle Paul in First
Corinthians 15 32
spoke about
um fighting the wild beasts
in Ephesus and so some people say well
he was in the he was in the Coliseum
fighting lions and tigers but Ellen
White has this interesting explanation
in sketches from the life of Paul Page
78.
uh Paul informed the the Corinthians of
his trouble in Asia where he says we
were pressed out of measure above
strength in so much that we despaired
even of life
in his first epistle he speaks of
fighting with beasts at Ephesus he thus
refers to the fanatical mob that
clamored for his life
they were indeed more like ferocious
wild beasts than men with gratitude to
God Paul reviews his danger and his
Deliverance he had thought when at
Ephesus that his life of usefulness was
about to close that the promise made to
him that he should at last die for his
faith was about to be fulfilled but God
had preserved him and his remarkable and
his remarkable to Deliverance made him
hope that his labors were not at an end
so the answer to this question is very
simple uh the demons are compared to the
birds and human beings are compared to
wild beasts it's symbolic language
pastor and in the chapter 19 that she
quotes and in verse
they're the 18 or 17 and 18.
it sort of tells you it's setting up the
the ex the the scenario of what's going
to happen at the very very end when
Christ is about to come there's going to
be this as you mentioned the spirits are
going to be led loose to destroy one
another to impress to bring perhaps
accusations you know upon those that
were deceived they realized they are
lost and the anger the the hate they
have now they jump when another like
beasts so there is this concept of
Destruction among the wicked and then in
verse um 21 of that same chapters
speaking of Jesus you know and says in
this Remnant where it's Lane with the
sword of him that set upon the horse
which sword proceeded out of his mouth
and all the fouls were filled with their
flesh so it's telling you that like you
mentioned Christ with the sword you know
kind of destroying or or his for through
his word destroying the remnant whoever
were left and all these Devils demons
did their work of
destruction because that's what
ultimately what sin brings or will lead
them into and the final thing that she
wants to connect is with the thousands
of years of course a thousand years are
in chapter 20 there verse two it speaks
of how he they laid hold of the Satan
and is cast into the bottomless pit and
Bound for a thousand years to dwell upon
all the evidence of sin that he has now
seen or the consequences of sin it's
really the ultimate scenario to
put I guess a prison to to Satan to
think about the consequence of saying
what it really brings out you know
what's what really brought which is
nothing destruction desolation
uh evil nothing good came out of that
Rebellion you know an example of how
Satan uh uses his power even to get his
own people to destroy one another is uh
the French Revolution you know it's a
beast from the bottomless pit according
to Revelation 11 Ellen White says that
that was a manifestation of satanic
power
Satan can lead his own people to turn
against one another of course to cause
chaos and turmoil Etc he not only uses
people while they're alive to accomplish
his purposes he turns people against
people and that's exactly what's going
to happen during the period of the sixth
and seventh plague the wicked are going
to turn against one another which is the
result of demonic power that is in
control
well time flies when you're having a
good time amen we want you to please
send us your questions TV at some tv.org
thank you for joining us hope to see you
next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign